LUC DE BRABANDERE: Good morning,
good afternoon.
Creativity is all my life.
I'm doing this job for the
last 40 years, and as an
amateur for 20 years.
And when I was 40 I went
through what's called a
midlife crisis, but probably
you don't know what it is--
it's when you ask yourself,
OK, what about
the second half time?
And then I decided to turn
my passion into a job.
And that's how I'm here today,
so it was a good decision.
So I run probably, maybe
1,500 brainstorms.
This And today I
have strange--
not strange, but some
observations.
And probably one that
is particularly
striking is this one.
If you take this expression,
creative thinking, in the end
the key word is not creative.
I'm convinced the keyword
is thinking.
Creativity is not a byproduct,
but it's a subset of something
much more sophisticated
called thinking.
So my 15 minutes before handing
over to Alan, my 15
minutes is not about
creativity.
It's about thinking.
And I'm convinced that if
thinking process is better
understood, it's for
profit for any
kind of creative session.
So what is to think?
What is to think?
And let's start with
this observation.
If a father or a mother tells
somebody, I'm thinking about
my children, this is true.
If the CEO of a bank tells a
journalist, I'm thinking about
my clients, this is not true.
Because it's impossible.
Probably you are in the
same situation.
If somebody at Google says, I'm
thinking about the users,
it's not true.
At least it's not true
the same way as for
a father or a mother.
When you think about your user,
because of course you
do, what do you do?
AUDIENCE: Generalize.
LUC DE BRABANDERE: You--
LUC DE BRABANDERE: I prefer
another words.
You simplify.
There is no other choice.
The CEO of a bank, if he wants
to think about the market, he
has to segment the market--
seven, eight, nine segments.
And generalization and
simplification are more or
less synonymous.
And this is a good
start for today.
If you want to think about
anything you have to simplify
this particular thing into
categories, segments,
clusters, boxes--
because of course there's
a lot about boxes now.
And it's probably the key word
of the whole process, to
remember that at any time when
we think, we simplify.
I'm going to use this
for maybe four
words and two arrows.
In front of you, you
have the world.
The world is moving, uncertain,
diverse, complex,
and partly hidden.
But you see about the world.
You are here and you want to
think about the world.
And you made the point, in
your mind you only have
simplification.
So I put here, simplification.
Most of the time when
we tell about a
situation, this is simple.
We should say it's simplified
because nothing is simple.
And if you take for example a
rainbow, you have the rainbow
with a million colors--
in your mind, seven colors.
You have a million clients, in
your mind, eight, seven, four
categories, et cetera.
We have simplifications.
So if you take the metaphor,
thinking is to play, and I
like this metaphor--
this is the playground.
That's where it happens.
And of course a game
has rules.
And the rules of thinking are
not that sophisticated.
It happens here.
So you immediately realize it
goes in both directions.
And I'm going to simplify, of
course, with two arrows.
One is here and the
other is here.
When you think, either you are
here or you are there.
Let's take the CEO
of the bank.
He has segmentation, seven
categories, he can call
Ogilvie and other advertisers
and say, OK,
I have seven segments.
You should talk to those people
differently, et cetera.
He is here.
The starting point is a
simplification, seven boxes.
And then he works a lot.
So go, go, et cetera.
But he's definitely here.
To me, this arrow is
more important.
And those two arrows correspond
to keywords in
philosophy.
This deduction and this
is induction.
And of course, completely
different.
Deduction is when you move
from the idea, the
simplification.
An idea is a simplification.
When you move from the idea
to the world, you deduce.
You want to go on vacation
in Belgium, it's a
simplification.
You can call, and say
cheap airline, et
cetera, so this deduction.
I'm convinced one day there
is going to be completely
[INAUDIBLE].
I don't see any reason why it
shouldn't be like that.
Today you have still
some problem.
But OK, this is not
a challenge.
The real challenge is here.
How do we simply the world?
How do we simplify?
Because this is the world and
you are king of the algorithm,
of course you don't have
algorithm here.
You have what we call
heuristics.
It's a way to find.
But what's a heuristic?
If you lose your key,
how do you find your
key back with a heuristic?
Yesterday I was--
no, this is heuristics.
Finally you've got your key.
But it's not an algorithm.
There is no certainty.
So this is algorithm,
this is heuristic.
And next step is to realize that
deduction can be perfect.
If you do it twice, you have
twice the same result.
Induction cannot be perfect.
Why?
Because a perfect induction
would require an infinite
amount of time.
Because you have to
embrace the whole
world, the whole world.
And this is of course
not possible.
Because first, most of
the world is hidden.
Sometimes you are in contact
with the reality of the world.
When you interview somebody, for
example, there is nothing
between the person
and yourself.
At the end of the 30
minutes, you have a
simplification in your mind.
This person's good,
not good, bad.
You're doing simplification.
But this is, in the end,
maybe the exception.
Most of the time what
do you have here?
Simplifications of
other people--
if you have reporters, a
newspaper, any kind of book--
they are all someone else's
simplification.
So even world et cetera.
So the induction cannot be
perfect, because it's not
rational to be 100% rational.
Which is a bit striking.
If you want to buy your next
vacation, and then you say,
OK, I'm going to go next
vacation with full, 100%
rational procedure, you'll
never go on vacation.
Because you need to embrace the
whole, what's the market,
all possibilities.
One day you say, OK,
I got to Belgium--
just an example.
And it means that when you
induce at a given time, you
have to give up rationality.
There is no perfect way to
guarantee the simplification
is the best one.
On this side, you only
have hypothesis.
A segmentation is
a hypothesis.
All the segmentation do
exist, and there is no
algorithm to show--
of course you can make some
trial and error, but you could
never achieve certainty.
So let's make a little
exercise around this.
I'll have two little
sentences.
And I will not finish the
sentence, and I will ask you
to finish rapidly.
OK, ready?
Sentence number one--
an example of a car is?
AUDIENCE: A Nissan.
LUC DE BRABANDERE: A Nissan.
Perfect.
[FRENCH], sorry, second--
Nissan, is Renault, and Renault
is [INAUDIBLE].
OK, so this wrong.
Second sentence--
the car is an example of?
AUDIENCE: A vehicle.
LUC DE BRABANDERE: Vehicle.
AUDIENCE: Transportation.
LUC DE BRABANDERE:
Transportaion.
The care is an example of--
engineering.
Genius, the car is an
example of a big
problem in the near future.
The car is an example of
something I'd like to drive.
You have understood
the whole thing.
Look what happened.
First sentence, an example
of a car is a Nissan.
It took a millisecond,
not a big deal.
So you could say a Renault,
Ferrari, Mercedes, Audi.
What happens?
You're starting point
is a simplification.
In your mind, what is a car?
And you go down to the world.
And you have a Renault and
Nissan, it's not a big deal.
No discussion, no room for--
[FRENCH].
Look at the other sentence.
The car is an example of--
what came first?
Vehicle.
OK, fine, this is called
comfort zone.
Because it's a no risk answer.
It's the souvenir of
an old deduction.
An example of a vehicle is
a car, the car is an
example of a vehicle.
OK, so no discussion, no risk,
no danger, nothing.
But if you realize that the
second sentence can receive a
lot of different answers--
so I gave some rules.
So then you said transportation,
then you said
engineering, and whoo-- and you
say the car is an example
of a word with three letters,
and et cetera.
So I summarize--
it means that here we should
remember at any time there is
a lot of freedom here.
In this arrow you don't have
room for creativity.
You are down to the example
of cars, Nissan, OK, good.
You can improve the Nissan.
But the real creativity
happens here.
When you remember that this
can be organized in a
completely different way.
Just an example, and then
I hand over to Alan.
This is the cafeteria.
Imagine--
let's look at, I'm
going to simplify
the story of Starbucks.
I don't know those people, never
worked there, so just
the way I see it.
The first idea is, OK, I'm going
to make good coffee and
sell it everywhere.
The idea is the coffee,
and then you go down.
And then you have Starbucks and
Starbucks and so, you have
different coffee with
a lot of ch-ch-ch.
OK, but you're stuck
in the coffee.
What could happen
with Starbucks?
Imagine, you ask people, could
you please see your business
without using the word coffee?
No, we're coffee, come on.
Let's try your business without
using the word coffee.
One answer could be,
[INAUDIBLE].
We have the largest office in
the world, if you add all
Starbucks, probably you have
the largest office.
So it means that you take the
world of Starbucks and
suddenly, you move from the idea
of coffee, which is here.
You move to the idea of
office, like this.
And then you can have--
if you think, my business
is not about
coffee, I'm an office.
I rent square meters
or square feet.
So I compete with others.
You can have completely
different idea.
Not the cappuccino, you
could say, OK, I'm
going to put a printer.
Or I see it like this.
And I read recently that in
St. Petersburg and Moscow,
there is a new concept
for cafeteria.
Everything is free,
but the time.
Probably you're aware, and
probably now it comes.
But this kind of idea never
comes if you have in your mind
one box for coffee.
Because it's not possible.
And so it's all about the
freedom you have to look at
the world in front of
you, your market or
competitor, et cetera.
And to build other
simplifications.
Coffee is a simplification.
Office is a simplification.
But that the beauty is
to do this, voila.
I hand over to Alan for more.
This is what I used in the
last century, so I
feel better with this.
ALAN INY: I'm going to keep
referring to it, but I'm going
to put it here.
Because in this century
we also have this.
Luc gave you a beautiful model,
a beautiful box--
I could put box here as
another synonym--
for how thinking works.
And creativity is what we're
going to come to now.
Creativity is essentially this
process here, the idea of all
of this arrow, everything that
happens here, this is the
invitation to be creative.
It's giving you the invitation
to not just say that a car is
a vehicle or mode of
transportation, which is of
course not wrong, but to
actually go beyond that.
And to say a car is something
you like to draw, or something
you like to ride in with your
second cousins on your way to
a baseball game, or
whatever you want.
Anything, you have the
invitation to go
as far as you want.
And if box is another word for
what comes here, then this is
an interesting thing.
Because for 50 years,
we have been told,
think outside the box.
Just go in a room, take a plate
of cookies, gather a
bunch of people.
Think outside the box.
Solve all your problems.
And yet when I ask executives,
whatever the industry or
wherever around the world,
have you had
creative session lately?
Have you had a brainstorm?
Everybody says, yes,
yes, yes, yes.
But are you really happy
with the results?
Are you satisfied with it?
People tend to say no, it was
a little bit frustrating.
We didn't get exactly where we
wanted to get to, et cetera.
And one of the reasons for that
is that thinking outside
the box is simply
not sufficient.
No matter what we do, we're
going to use a lot of boxes.
We have a lot of boxes that
process and help us interpret
the world in front of us.
Everything we do is
governed by boxes.
It's unavoidable.
So thinking outside the box,
to stick with the cars, is
like telling you don't
drive on the highway.
But it's not telling you if
you should take the side
roads, or take a helicopter, or
use a video conference, or
something else instead.
So think outside the box gives
you absolutely no direction
for where to find the new one.
And that of course is the point
of "Thinking In New
Boxes," and the book that is
available at the back.
And so what I'd like to do is
really take you through this
five step process for thinking
in new boxes that is outlined
in the book.
I will do so very quickly.
And I will do so without using
classic consultant BCG type
slides like this one, starting
after this one.
So the first step is doubt.
The first step is doubt.
And what do I really
mean by doubt?
The whole point of doubt is to
actually start by identifying
some of your current boxes
and challenge them.
And that is a step that so
many people often miss.
If somebody walks straight
into a room and
says, we need new ideas.
Think outside the box.
Then they're jumping straight
to this idea of divergence,
getting a lot of ideas
on the table.
And that's fine.
I have no problem with the
traditional brainstorm.
It's just that you can't
start there.
You have to prepare.
You have to be ready.
And you have to start
with doubt.
And I'll give you a couple of
examples of what I mean.
In fact, I'll give you an
example, forget the slides,
from two days ago.
Luc and I, celebrating
our launch, 8
o'clock in the morning.
We needed to go for a coffee.
Not Starbucks, in this
case actually--
we went across the street to
another coffee shop that was
right there.
And at the register, instead
of a tip jar, there were
actually two tip jars.
And in between the two tip
jars there was a piece of
paper that said, which TV
family do you prefer?
The Huxtables from "The Cosby
Show" or the Tanners from
"Full House"?
And there was an arrow pointing
to each tip jar.
Now, I thought to myself
this is fantastic.
This is a new box.
This is a complete re-conception
of what the tip
jar can be.
Because people who probably feel
very strongly about it
would be more inclined to leave
a tip in one of the two
jars, based on that, right.
And you could tell, actually--
perhaps it will or won't
surprise you, I don't know--
but the Huxtables jar
was much fuller.
So I thought, how interesting.
May I please take a picture?
I took a picture.
I tweeted it.
I went and sat down.
Then I actually went back there
and started talking to
the ladies behind the
register, and
asking some more questions.
Because being a consultant, I
wanted to learn more about the
actual data.
And it turns out, OK, they
change the question every day.
And most importantly, the amount
of their tips went up
by 50% since they did this.
So the idea of taking your
mental box of what is a tip
jar-- they could've gone their
whole lives without actually
changing that.
You can go through life saying
a tip jar is a tip jar.
But they had a completely new
box, a new hypothesis, a new
idea for what the tip
jar could be.
And it had a dramatic impact
on their particular world.
Now this is not necessarily the
invention of penicillin,
or the iPhone, or whatever you
want, but it is a game
changing thing.
It fundamentally changed
their particular world.
And whatever the problem is that
you're facing, the best
way to get at it is to challenge
some of your
existing boxes.
And the best way to challenge
them, to doubt them, is to
actually start by identifying
some of them.
And I want to show you a few
cartoons that kind of explain
why that is.
Because if we accept that all of
our boxes, all of our ideas
are simply working hypotheses
that we arrive at through
induction, we have to
challenge those.
Because to paraphrase Immanuel
Kant, we don't see
the world as it is.
We see the world as we are.
In other words, we each see
the world through our own
boxes, through our own lenses.
And this is Immanuel Kant's
favorite cartoon--
would have been.
Here's another example.
When we see something, whether
it's an optical illusion, or
whether it's an image, or
whether it's calculations, or
whether these perceived
limitations--
like when there's a new idea,
oh, the boss will
never go for that.
We can't do that.
Our competitor tried that
and it doesn't work.
All of these things,
we have to doubt.
We have to foster doubt.
And I'll give you a quick visual
example, even though
this is true in really serious
business situations as well.
So what is this?
You look at this, and you say,
well, this is George W. Bush
upside down.
And then you just go back to
whatever you're doing and
that's fine.
In a split second, your mind
says this is George W. Bush
upside down.
And now to save you the trouble
of going like this, I
flip it for you.
And you see that somebody
has actually
Photoshopped this thing--
the mouth in particular,
and the eyes as well.
And they have cleverly,
not cleverly--
I mean, let's be clear.
You can do this for the Queen,
or Obama, or whoever you want.
It's not a political statement,
of course.
But somebody has Photoshopped
this.
But here's the interesting
thing.
If you go back and look at this
again tomorrow, or even
now, your mind immediately says,
oh, it's George W. Bush
upside down.
Now you're staring at it.
You're starting to notice
the mouth and the eyes.
But immediately your mind jumps
to these conclusions
because the brain is lazy when
it processes information.
And when we go through this
process of seeing something in
the world in front of us and
trying to find a box for it,
we immediately go for the
simplest solution.
And 99.9% of the time,
that's fantastic.
It's usually helpful.
It's usually correct.
And it's an amazing benefit
of being human that many
companies, including Google,
have tried to replicate.
Think IBM trying to have a
computer that plays chess, or
a computer that plays Jeopardy!,
and all the stuff
that you guys do.
It's an amazing thing of trying
to replicate what the
human brain actually does
just like that.
But, occasionally, the human
brain is misleading.
And the more we allow ourselves
to challenge our
instincts, to doubts these
boxes, and recognize that
maybe this group that we've
always thought of as our
customers could be broader
or narrower.
And maybe the way that we've
always looked at this
particular segment, or the
strategy that we've always
held, might be open
to reinvention--
these are the kinds of things
that we need to doubt.
Another example, what's this?
12, 13, 14.
This is what most of us
would normally say.
And if I were to show you this,
you would very naturally
say, A, B, C. Nobody's going to
say A, 13, C or 12, B, 14
on the other one.
But again, there's often more
than one correct way to
interpret something.
The context always matters.
And you may think this is just
a silly visual exercise.
It's just as true in business.
I'll give you an example, the
annual report of maybe not
Google because you have some
fun stuff, but the annual
report of a typical Fortune
500 company.
You open it.
The first page is what?
A letter from the CEO.
Now I am going to oversimplify,
because that is
what I do, and tell you that
there are only two possible
letters from the CEO that can
appear there, basically.
Number one, dear shareholders,
the results this year have
been excellent thanks to some
fantastic strategic decisions
that we made ba bum
bum bum bum.
Number two, dear shareholders,
the results this year has been
quite disappointing because of
volcanic ash, terrorism,
recession, and all of
the other stuff
that's out of our control.
We'll try and do better
next time.
So you're never going to have
a letter with the exact same
financial results inside that
says, dear shareholders, we
had fantastic results because
we were really lucky.
And we hope that holds.
Or dear shareholders, we had
disappointing results this
year because we screwed up a
little bit and we did some
stupid decisions.
But we're going to really
do better next year.
We promise, trust us.
You're not going to have that.
But even if the numbers are
exactly the same, if your
customer research or trends
about what's happening in the
world are exactly the same,
there are multiple ways to
interpret it.
So this is not just a 12,13,
14 silly example.
It's important and relevant
in the business world.
This is another example of the
context being really important
and how our minds jump
to conclusions.
This one might take
a few seconds.
That's doubt.
Always start by challenging some
of your existing boxes,
some of your existing
perspectives.
Because once you do that,
the rest is relatively
straightforward.
When I say explore, for example,
this is the stuff
that we generally
know how to do.
We can go and look at the 23 top
mega trends impacting our
space, or a massive customer
survey of 2000 people, or
competitive intelligence,
or network analysis.
Whatever it is, we generally
know how to do that.
But just be careful to
always maintain the
atmosphere of doubt.
Just checking--
always be careful to keep this
atmosphere of doubt alive and
challenge the way you're looking
at these things.
Look at them with
fresh lenses.
That's the best advice for
this explore phase.
OK, so once we doubt, once we
explore, we have to think
about the future.
And in trying to think
creatively about the future
there will always be surprises,
like this.
There will always be what are
called wild cards, black
swans, there's a lot
of words for them.
These high impact but low
probability events that are
very obvious in retrospect.
And the reason these
are so important--
not just in this example, but
volcanic ash or Gates giving
all his money to developing
world, stuff like that--
the reason these are so
important is because when we
think about the future, we have
a very natural tendency
to do it based on the past.
And there's a lot of very
famous examples of this.
The funnest one for today, of
course, is Steve Ballmer
saying in 2007, there's no
chance that the iPhone is
going to get any significant
market share.
But there's hundreds
of those quotes.
Margaret Thatcher saying in
1969, I don't think there will
be a woman prime minister
in my lifetime--
any of these things.
We are not good at predicting
the future and we are
overconfident.
All the more reason that when we
explore, when we gather all
of these facts about the world
in front of us, we need to
keep this feeling of doubt.
So once we do that, once we
go through the process of
identifying and challenging some
of our existing mental
models, then we can go into
the creative process.
And this is the stuff, in terms
of divergence, getting a
lot of ideas on the table
without judgment.
Quantity is good.
Because whatever the criteria
are that you've set for what
is a good idea, there are going
to be some that exceed
the hurdle and some
that don't.
And so Linus Pauling, a double
Nobel Prize winner, said the
best way to have a good idea
is to have a lot of ideas.
And many people like Edison
and others would certainly
subscribe to that.
Edison was a big believer in--
when somebody asked him, are
you going to give up?
You've been working on the
light bulb for so long.
He famously said something like,
well, now I know 999
ways that it doesn't work.
He didn't give up.
And he had a whole pile of
inventions, as well.
I won't go too much into that,
but the main point again--
divergence, get a lot of
ideas on the table.
Convergence, select among them,
the prioritization.
By the way, never try and do
both of them at the same time.
The most frustrating thing in
any creative process is when
some people in the room are just
listing a lot of ideas,
and other people in the
room are picking them
apart one by one.
And it's just thoroughly
frustrating for both sides.
You've probably been in both.
So there's a time
for divergence.
There's a time for
convergence.
Remember that you will have no
way of knowing a priori, no
way of knowing upfront, which
are the more incremental
ideas, like the two bladed razor
and the three bladed
razor and the four blade razor,
or the iPhone 3, 4, 5,
et cetera and which are the
truly transformational ideas,
like the original iPhone and
penicillin and the Model T
Ford, and all the rest of it.
So you have to get it
all on the table.
And also you have no way of
knowing a priori which are the
good ones and which
are the bad ones.
So again, quantity first.
Divergence first.
I put in here a few of my
favorite type questions.
I know that our time is a little
bit limited and I want
to leave time for Q and A. So
I'm not going to dwell on
these, just to say there is an
infinite number of ways to ask
fun questions in a creativity
workshop.
If you go in and just say, how
can we be more creative?
How can we grow?
How can we cut costs?
We need more ideas to double our
size, or whatever it is,
you're not really likely to
get interesting things.
If you try and change
perspective, make it more
visual, reformulate the question
in a fun way--
then you are much, much more
likely to get much more
interesting results.
If you are trying to cut costs
in creative ways then don't
just say what are some ideas.
Say how would executives
at Ryanair do this?
If you're trying to think about
the customer experience
in fun ways, how would
executives at Disney do this?
What would a joint venture
with the New York Times
possibly lead to?
What sorts of things would I
have thought of if I were on
my first day out of college?
Or what sorts of ideas would
my grandmother think of?
All these kinds of what if type
questions help push us
outside of our existing boxes
and help us find new ones.
That's the point.
And there's no shortage
of ways to do that.
So the last step then
is to reevaluate.
And this kind of takes
us back to doubt.
This is about always remembering
that no good idea
is good forever.
And that applies again, to
penicillin, the Model T Ford,
and anything else.
No good idea is good forever
because the world keeps
changing around us.
And you can say, maybe in some
industries it might last for
five years.
And in other industries a good
idea can last for 20 years.
That's all fine.
But one thing's for sure, in
today's world business cycles
are getting shorter across
all industries.
The lifespan of a good idea is
getting shorter and shorter
almost everywhere.
And this just makes creativity
even more important than it
ever has been before.
So remember that no good
idea is good forever.
Henry Ford, famously, no matter
how amazing the Model T
was, when General Motors and
others started changing, and
coming up with higher end cars,
and lower end cars, and
all the rest--
different color cars--
his famous quote, of course, was
my customers can have any
color car they want, as
long as it's black.
He refused to change.
He was a fantastically
innovative guy, but he was
still human.
And all of us go through life
with blinders on, wedded to
our existing models.
And so the more we can force
ourselves to go back to doubt,
to challenge that this Model T,
which has sold 15 million
units, and even today is one
of the best selling cars of
all time, is going to be
a good idea forever.
Challenge those perspectives.
One more example, just from the
business world, is Reuters.
Now in the last few
years it was, of
course, acquired by Thomson.
But quite interestingly, its
core box has stayed exactly
the same for 160 years.
Reuters, we think of their box
as stock price delivery or
news delivery.
Now, they were founded in 1851
by Julius Reuter in what was
then Prussia, now Germany.
And their original,
overarching box--
what is our mission?
What is our goal?
To deliver the news
and stock prices.
At the time, it was from Europe
to the United Kingdom.
How did they do it in 1851?
They had a fleet of carrier
pigeons to get the news and
stock prices across the
English Channel.
And so the interesting thing
about Reuters is that over the
last 160 years, of course
they've had to reinvent
themselves fundamentally, they
moved eventually to the
telegraph and they piloted
it and they
competed against others.
And then they went to radio
technology, and eventually in
the last few decades to
satellites and the internet
and fiber optic, all
the rest of it.
In other words, in order to keep
doing exactly the same
thing, they had to fundamentally
reinvent
themselves no less
than five times.
And at any point, in any of
those transitions they could
have been beaten by
a competitor.
But the only reason they
survived is because they were
constantly willing to
reevaluate, to doubt, to
challenge the fact that the way
things have been done so
far will always work.
No good idea is good forever.
And we don't like it when
we have to change our
perspective.
When someone forces us out of
our existing box, like Henry
Ford we sometimes
go into denial.
We don't like to change.
We have to allow ourselves
to do so.
We have to foster a culture
where that sort of thing is
encouraged.
And at least when you
look at the--
I don't know what it's actually
like to work here,
but everybody's perception is
that this is the type of
culture where that sort of thing
is, in fact, encouraged.
Where people are encouraged to
challenge the status quo and
think about things
differently.
That's the perception on surveys
and in the media.
You can tell me after whether
it's true or not.
But that's everybody sense
in the outside world.
So a quick poll, multiple
choice question.
Which of the following is
absolutely essential for a
successful brainstorm?
A big plate of cookies, the
latest technology, a fresh
setting, a new perspective,
coming up with new ideas, or
none of the above?
Who says A?
Well, OK.
You have awesome food in
the cafeterias here.
That's great.
Who says B?
Who says C?
OK, who says D?
And who says E?
OK, so a lot of D's and E's, and
maybe one person on A, B,
C. And I will just tell you
one last quick story then,
about why for us, at least, in
this particular box the answer
is in fact E. And why it is
possible to be very, very
creative and have an amazing
creative session without
coming up with a single
new idea.
An example, Bic, the French
company founded after World
War II by Marcel Bic, for 30
years they made only pens.
So imagine then, it's the
'70s, 30 years later.
And you have the executive
team thinking
about how to grow.
We need to grow.
We need new ways to grow.
And some of the executives Holly
will say, maybe we can
make these four color pens.
And Henley might say, we
need erasable pens.
We could do erasable pens.
And we could refillable pens.
And we could do branded pens
that say Sheraton or Hilton on
them, or whatever you want.
And then you suddenly say, we
could do lighters, or razors.
The immediate reaction from your
colleagues is bound to
be, what a crazy idea.
We're a pen company.
And yet with 40 years of
hindsight we all now know that
they made a lot of money off
of lighters and razors.
So what happened?
What had to happen?
Each of the executives in the
room had to change their box
from we are a pen company to
we are a disposable plastic
consumer goods company,
or some such thing.
It doesn't roll off the tongue
in the same way.
But it's OK.
We are a plastic
goods company.
And if that is your box, then
lighters and razors are a
perfectly logical idea.
They're perfectly reasonable.
And in fact it did open
the door to all sorts
of things for them.
Now that doesn't mean that
erasable pens and all the
other ideas were bad ideas.
They were just more incremental
ideas, like the
two bladed razor and the three
bladed razor that came after.
But the truly transformational
ones require a change in box.
But here's the most
interesting thing.
Gillette was already
making cheap
disposable plastic razors.
The lighters existed, too.
In other words, they opened the
door in a creative way to
all sorts of new possibilities
simply by changing one of
their boxes on this side.
Nothing changed on this side.
They didn't actually invent
something new.
They were very creative without
coming up with a
single new idea.
So that's the point.
Creativity is about changing
perspective.
It's about changing
your boxes.
And it can be the box for how
you look at your company,
yourself, your customers,
your competitors.
It can help you with a midlife
crisis, or changing an
organization design, or
whatever you want.
It doesn't only have to be about
new product development.
Creativity is about changing
perspective.
And so that is a good
way to end, with
one last visual thing.
So we, using our quick
heuristics, can immediately
decide what this says.
Whereas a computer, like
Watson or any sort of
artificial intelligence, would
look at all the possible
permutations in a deductive way
of what this could say.
We immediately look
at that and say,
well, it says, be creative.
In a split second, right?
And yet, we have to
always doubt.
Be creative, but always doubt.
So that is the sort of lightning
version of the five
steps to "Thinking in New
Boxes." It's about philosophy,
and how we think.
But it's also about practicality
and how we can
actually make this happen
in the business world.
So be creative, but
always doubt.
So thank you very much.
We have a chunk of time for
questions, I think.
AUDIENCE: I'm just wondering
about the doubt part.
How do you figure out, or
apply that to, sort of a
complex problem, right?
Do you start doubting
everything?
Do you start doubting every
foundational idea that has
come before it?
Where do you--
where is it effective
to doubt?
Or what is it effective
Well, you're matching,
so you both--
you wore your matching
outfits today.
ALAN INY: Yesterday, too,
by coincidence.
AUDIENCE: You've spent a lot
of time together, I assume.
LUC DE BRABANDERE: So probably
the first thing to do is to
give a good definition
of what is to doubt.
To doubt is not a kind
of bad feeling.
It's about, remember, at any
time that here, you only have
simplifications.
So that's to doubt.
I like to tell, great
managers never
hesitate and always doubt.
So if you're a manager, and
somebody asks you, the client
doesn't pay-- send a reminder.
The machine is broken--
call the company.
You don't hesitate.
But you should remember at any
time that if it's possible for
you not to hesitate, it is
because one day you select one
simplification, a strategy,
you're going to do this.
And doubt is on the
other side.
It's just a reminder.
It's just, we are built with
simplification in our mind,
assumption.
And to doubt is from time to
time to challenge those
assumptions.
So to answer your question, the
first thing to I believe,
is to list your assumptions.
And sometimes they
are unconscious.
We always said this,
why [INAUDIBLE].
Maybe we can do that
differently.
So you know what I mean?
ALAN INY: Let me add
to that and give a
business example as well.
Because I think this idea of,
identifying as many of your
assumptions--
and of course you can't change
them all at the same time.
That's when you would
become sort of a
caricature of a good manager.
You can't change everything.
But imagine 40, 50 years ago,
all of the airlines are the
sort of traditional Pan Am,
British Airways type.
And there's no such thing yet
as a low cost airline.
So what are the very specific
assumptions and constraints
that have to change?
Well, we have many types of
planes to serve different
definitions.
We have one type of plane,
because it's cheaper.
We go to the main airports
in each city.
We are going to go to
secondary airports.
We have assigned seating.
We have open seating.
We have all-inclusive pricing.
We have unbundled pricing.
We use travel agents.
We don't use travel agents.
All of these things, to be very
specific about what your
existing assumptions and boxes
are, and then figure out which
ones of them you're very
deliberately going to change,
which constraints you're
going to break--
that's what we mean by doubt.
What else?
AUDIENCE: One of the challenges
that comes to my
mind is [INAUDIBLE] the velocity
of execution rate.
We live in a world with this
[INAUDIBLE] pressure, we have
to get things out.
So this sounds great, but I'm
wondering if you have any tips
on making it more practical,
sellable.
Let's say you want to start
doubting, or like the person
is [INAUDIBLE].
You have to give yourself time
and space to allow for that
exercise to happen.
[INAUDIBLE].
Have you faced that in
your discussions?
And what has worked for you to
encourage and get people to
actually say, aha, we need
to take this on.
LUC DE BRABANDERE: Part of the
answer is called scenario.
So part of the future
you can more or less
expect, based on forecast.
The other part [INAUDIBLE],
including the ash of volcano,
there's no way to make
any kind of forecast.
So we recommend to increase
preparation.
And so if you take uncertainty
on the right side of my
[INAUDIBLE], the other
side of the
simplification is called scenario.
In this particular case,
a set of scenarios.
So there is a way to disseminate
the language of
uncertainty.
We did that, maybe fifty times
in company, just like this
habit, to live with
uncertainty in
your mind, like this.
And so now you're thinking of
the best way to do that, using
this method.
ALAN INY: So I agree with the
idea of using scenarios to
embrace uncertainty.
Because even if our natural
tendency is to try and
eliminate it, if we realize that
we never can, then let's
embrace it.
But on the more individual
level, in terms of how to
foster doubt, how to set this
up in organizations, my best
suggestion is that sometimes
these kinds of thought
exercises, like describe your
company without using the most
obvious words like coffee,
like Luc tried earlier--
there's a lot of these that
can be done in 10 minutes.
There's a lot of these that can
be done by shutting the
laptop, taking a white piece of
paper, or a flip chart, or
a blank document, whatever
you want.
And just thinking
a little bit.
You don't need to take eight
hours and methodically list
all of your assumptions,
though over
time that can't hurt.
But to be very quick and
specific about it, you can
still make some progress.
What else?
Please.
AUDIENCE: Apart from the tip
jar example that you gave,
what is one of the most
interesting new boxes that
you've seen on the fly?
LUC DE BRABANDERE: My answer
would be Google.
Because when you started, the
box, the simplification was,
we're going to build
a search engine.
And so for a couple of years
that was the main vision.
So we have to do this.
But imagine that nobody would
have changed that?
Today, no Google anymore.
It's because one day you had
this famous meme, let's manage
the information of the world
or something like that.
That's one of the most beautiful
examples I know.
Otherwise, no Google in
the world, definitely.
And probably you have more.
But that's an example
I very often give.
ALAN INY: I saw a curved
escalator a
couple of days ago.
Sixth floor, down to the
fifth floor, like this.
Just in terms of ones I
see on the fly, right?
Not the big, the Google-- all
of these are fantastic
example, sure.
But like the tip jar, something
I just happened--
I was at the Bloomberg
building.
And a curved escalator,
it was fantastic.
And very expensive,
by the way--
I asked about that,
too, afterward.
AUDIENCE: Another question.
You had an interesting example
of Bic and the pens, and how
they redefined themselves from
a pen company to a disposable
plastics company.
And I'm wondering, have you
seen companies go through
multiple iterations?
So you redefine yourself
once, are they stuck
with this new box?
Have you seen companies go
through this multiple times?
[INAUDIBLE]
LUC DE BRABANDERE: Reuters
was a good example.
Reuters.
ALAN INY: Reuters is a good one
in the sense that, even
though they kept their big
overarching box of we are
this, they changed fundamentally
all of the
underlying mechanics of
how they did that.
So that's a good example
in some sense.
LUC DE BRABANDERE: A lot
of good examples.
Dannon, Dannon used to
be a glass company.
[INAUDIBLE], just glass,
manufacturing bottles.
And one day they said, OK, we
should focus on the contents.
And then after decades of being
a conglomerate, like
Nabisco, or whatever, known
for making food, quality
food-- they switched
their box again.
Instead of good food, they
switched to food
that's good for you.
And they sold off their beer
division, they sold off their
cookies division.
And now all of us know them as
water, and yogurt, and baby
food, I think.
So now they focus on healthy
food that's good.
Again, these multiple
switches do happen.
Tends to not be year after
year after year.
But it's fun when it does.
AUDIENCE: Reading about Pepsi
and what happened when the CEO
decided that they wanted
to focus more on
making healthier products.
And he tried it for
about a year.
And then there was a lot of
shareholder push back, and
they said don't do it.
And then he had to
switch back.
I'm asking, was that
the wrong idea?
Or could he have done it
in a way that worked?
ALAN INY: I'll give you another
example along those
lines, as well.
Because--
take Netflix.
In many ways, a fantastic
new box at first.
Changing, essentially killing
the video store, video rental
in a store business, and
replacing it with a new box of
DVD rental by mail.
OK, new box, 10 years, millions
of subscribers,
excellent--
then what happens?
Just like in the example you
said, they changed a little
bit too early for their
customers by trying to split
into two with the streaming
business as well as the mail.
And there was a huge outcry.
They lost hundreds of thousands
of subscribers and
shareholder value and all the
rest, very upsetting.
They recovered.
And now, who two years ago
would have predicted that
Netflix would have award-winning
original
television programming?
This is an extraordinary
new box, and
actually decent stuff.
And so really again,
continuously reevaluating and
rethinking some of
these things.
But you're right.
The main takeaway from what you
said is that there is a
right moment for any change.
And sometimes it'll
be too early.
Sometimes it'll be too late.
The most obvious example,
to me, is YouTube.
If somebody had invented that
a few years earlier there
would never been enough
bandwidth.
Nobody had enough bandwidth.
Not enough people had high speed
internet in their homes,
is what I'm trying to say, for
it to be very successful.
And of course, if they had
invented it a few years later,
someone else would have come
up with something.
And it would be called
something else.
So it is a question of timing.
You're quite right.
And Netflix, YouTube, and the
example you said are all good
examples of that.
It's about what is the right
new box and when?
Good, well, thank you very
much for having us here.
And we're available to stick
around and talk more.
Sign books if anyone takes them,
and really, it's lovely
to be here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]